[Music]
hello everyone
so in the previous lectures we had
talked about the plane stress and the
plane strain conditions
and at the end of it all we had
shown if we just refer back to the
previous page
that when we do not have body forces
or when the conservative body forces
said that
the scalar potential v satisfies this
laplacian of the scalar potential equal
to 0 then we must have
this equation this by harmonic equation
involving the airy stress function phi
and
let us remind ourselves once again that
this by harmonic equation
includes within it the information from
the compatibility equations
the constitutive law as well as the
stress equilibrium
so with this let us go for and try to
look at
some possible solutions of this y
harmonic equation
now operationally what is done is to
look
for solutions or a particular solution
forms to this biharmonic equation
so we have this equation and
we will first of all consider this by
harmonic equation
in the rectangular cartesian coordinate
system only please note
that all this while we have actually
been uh
been deriving everything in the
rectangular cartesian coordinate system
because if you look back at all our
considerations involving
this plane strain this was all plain
string
and if you go back further
all this was plain stress so in all
these previous
lectures we have been actually talking
within the
scope of rectangular cartesian
coordinate system only
however the equation that we are finally
arriving at
uh that is
this equation this y harmonic equation
is
uh true irrespective of the coordinate
system of choice
what i mean to say is that even though
it is derived
using as you have seen the rectangular
cartesian coordinate system the xy
coordinate system that is
but it is this particular from this
compact form
uh involving the by harmonic operator it
is very much
true even if we go to the polar
coordinate system for example okay
so uh but now we'll be only
uh interested in the rectangular
cartesian coordinate system so
what we're basically looking at here is
this equation therefore pi del x 4
plus twice del 4 phi
del x square del y square plus
del 4 pi del y o
equal to zero okay
all right so now uh the
one of the most common solution forms or
that is assumed
to satisfy this by harmonic equation is
the polynomial
form okay so we're interested in this
polynomial solutions
so the form that is actually assumed is
this okay written in a very general
sense it is uh
it is written like this
okay so where m and n
are uh are just
uh integers okay starting from zero
they may go up to as much as you like
okay so both m and n
uh start out from zero it can be zero
one two three four whatever
okay uh
and we require that this will
this particular form will satisfy this
equation
okay now if we just expand it out a
little bit
okay you will see that when we set m
equal to 0 and n equal to 0 we just have
this constant
term next if we take
m equal to 1
and n equal to 0 will have a
1 0 x
if we take m equal to 0 n equal to 1
will have a 0 1 y
and if we take m equal to 1 n equal to 1
we'll have this first quadratic term
a 1 1 x y and similarly you can
uh understand that we'll have other
terms of this sort
okay we can keep on writing them out as
much as we please
dot dot dot okay
now uh i think for a moment that
this phi is basically used to generate
the stresses okay so because
uh again we remind ourselves that
because we have our stresses
in this form that sigma xx is equal to
del square phi del y square
sigma yy is equal to del square
pi del x square and sigma
xy is equal to minus del square
phi del x del y
okay so if we take terms like this
if we take a term like this you see that
all the stresses are zero
in fact if you take this term also then
also all the stresses are zero
if you take this term also all the
stresses are zero
okay so uh whenever
we have uh so
please note here that let's write down
one of the first important points
that terms
with uh
m plus n less than equal to 1
they do not contribute to the stresses
and because they are trivially trivially
giving us zero stresses
okay they do not contribute to the
stresses
okay so it's pointless to take them okay
they are always going to give us trivial
cases that the stresses are always zero
okay not very interesting
next uh suppose we take the terms which
do give us some kind of a nonzero stress
spin so the first of those will be terms
will be will be a polynomial form which
involve
the second degree terms
so
so the second degree terms
will produce
a linear stress field what do we mean
by that
okay so we have already crossed out
these things okay these are
not very useful so suppose we take terms
uh containing the second degrees okay so
this one is a second degree term this is
a second degree term
this is the second degree term so if we
take these things
okay we have no other terms which are
second degree here so if we take these
so let's say our phi is equal to
[Music]
a 1 1 x y plus
a 2 0
x square plus a 0
to y square okay
then the sigma x x
that is uh we can write this down
directly sigma xx is equal to del square
phi del y square
so we'll have the contribution from this
we'll have this as twice a
0 2 okay the y vanishes
next we'll have sigma yy
is equal to uh
that's del square pi del x square so
we'll have that as
twice a two zero and sigma
x y that will be
minus of l square pi del x del y
because you do not have any contribution
from y here and no contribution from x
here
so these will not contribute but this
one will
so this is going to be minus a 1 1
now see this is very interesting a
second
so these second degree terms these are
producing
uh
so i shouldn't actually be writing this
as a linear stress field that's wrong
okay let me make this correction
the second degree terms will produce a
constant stress field
okay this is very important excuse me
just note down this collection
so when we have the second degree terms
the stresses are all constant okay all
the three
components of stresses these are
constants and what this means
is that
it is basically producing a combination
of either uniform tension or compression
into perpendicular directions together
with some kind of constant shear
okay so perhaps it will look
something like this that we
take a rectangular domain like this
where you note that this one can be our
x-axis
itself and this can be our y-axis
okay uh so
this kind of a stress field uh
will be produced when you have
a uniform tension
like this along the x direction
it could also be uniform compression
it just depends on what what is the sign
of this a02
we could have uh what
this sigma yy we could have
this sort of uniform tension or
equivalently
uniform compression
in the y direction let me write that
clearly this is our y
direction this is our x direction
or uh at the same time we could have
a uniform shear
okay that also is very much possible so
suppose
okay so that denotes uniform shear so
also here
that is very much possible
so uh because i have no space left here
i'll just
uh started this figure a little bit
okay so that represents some kind of
uniform shear also
next uh suppose we
go on to take the third degree terms
then what happens
so these third degree terms
this is what is going to produce a
linear stress field
so what i mean here is that i can be of
the form
a 3 0 x cube
plus a 2 1 x
square y plus a
1 2 x y square plus
a 0 3 y cube
so all four of these terms they are
cubic so the sigma x
x you please note uh
since this is del square phi del y
square so only
this term and this term is going are
going to contribute
and that will be uh
2 a 1 2 x
plus 6 a
0 3 y
next for sigma yy
will have l square pi del x square
which means that i will have a
contribution from this
first term the term involving the a30
i'll get a 6830x out of it and from this
term
which will be twice a 2 1
x and finally
for my sigma x y
so here i will have a contribution only
from
these terms involving the a21 and the
a12
and this one will be minus
twice a two one x
minus twice a 1
2 y
all right so this looks fairly
complicated
if you want to physically interpret it
so
as a simple uh
special case of it what we'll consider
is uh
suppose we take
okay so consider the
simple special case
where we have
a 1 2 is equal to
a q 1 is equal to
a 3 0 is equal to 0
you said this then what we'll have
is sigma x x is equal to
x a 0 3 y
sigma y y going to be equal to 0
and sigma x xy is also going to be equal
to zero
so basically this uh this uh sigma xx
here
is just linearly dependent on y and you
try to think
from uh from there in your studies you
have come across such a stress field
okay so let me just point out here
that if you take
if you consider a beam like this which
is under pure bending
then from our undergraduate studies we
know
that the stress field here
does indeed have this kind of a linear
distribution
we have this kind of a linear
distribution so also on this side
when you note that along the top fibers
of the beam we have this kind of a
tensile
nature of the stress and on the bottom
fibers of the beam
we have this kind of uh compressive
stresses
so this is very much under your bending
okay and this is
it is this kind of a situation which is
modeled
by this special case okay so uh
uh your your next intuition would be
that we should be going to the four
degree term and
that is something we can very much do
but uh
before we can discuss anything related
to that you please note
that whenever
we were taking in the previous page the
second degree term
and on this page this third degree term
we did not have to find any special
condition regarding the satisfaction of
the bioharmonic equation
so if you took this form of phi and just
plugged it back into the bioharmonic
equation
you will find that it is identically
satisfied
okay it is actually a zero equal to zero
form it is because
in none of the terms you have any uh any
of the
uh you don't have any terms which are
higher than three
because it is a it's these are cubic
terms so also
in the previous page when we considered
the second degree terms
uh all of them are only up to degree two
so we when you substitute in the by
harmonic equation
which is up to four or the derivatives
uh
you have basically a zero equal to zero
form so it satisfies identically
however if you take a fourth degree term
or a fifth degree term
then you will have to find special
conditions okay
so to satisfy this and that is what is
now we can write that down
terms with m plus
n less than equal to 3 are
identically satisfied
the by harmonic equation
for m plus n
greater than three special conditions
involving the coefficients
involving the various coefficients will
have to be found
all right so uh you can actually
go forth and try the four degree terms
uh let us not get into that in this
recorded lecture uh just algebra
now uh the basic preliminaries
regarding the satisfaction of this uh
regarding the use of this polynomial uh
functions uh or polynomial forms
for this uh area stress function that we
have discussed here
but uh this is just like the as i
mentioned
very basic preliminaries okay
so if we want to apply this to actual
problems
uh we have to start thinking about the
boundary conditions which must be
satisfied
okay now it will not always be
so neat and clean as this
okay so where we have maybe some kind of
a pure tension
or a pure compression in which case uh
these the values of these various
coefficients can be found out in an easy
manner
okay or perhaps it will not be as simple
as this kind of simple bending
also okay so for more complicated
problems we have to start thinking
about uh cleverly trying to uh
trying to adjust the various
coefficients and take various
combinations
in so for that we will have to follow
some kind of underlying principle
uh and that will discuss in the
next part of the lecture we'll also have
to take something else into account
uh if we think a little bit carefully
okay so that also will be discussed in
the next part of the lecture
all right thank you very much